do you find that mr depp has proven all
the elements of defamation
answer yes
has mr dent proven by a greater weight
of the evidence
that question the statement was made or
published by ms heard answer yes
the state question the statement was
about mr depp answer yes
question the statement was false
answer yes
question the statement has a defamatory
implication about mr deb
answer yes
question the
defamatory implication was designed and
intended by ms heard answer yes
okay so the johnny depp versus amber
heard trial has reached a verdict and we
now know the outcome of it the jury
decided that depp was correct in his
defamation claim and awarded him with 15
million dollars in total this was
brought down to 10 million 350 000 due
to caps in the state they also decided
that amber was correct in one count of
her defamation claim and awarded her
with two million dollars throughout this
video we're going to be going over the
result why it went the way it did and
also the last two days of the trial
which were arguably the most important
out of the entire thing i've constantly
had to remind people that this is a
defamation case centered primarily
around the op-ed that amber hood wrote
though this didn't name johnny his legal
team had been arguing that it was
clearly about him and that it also
ruined his career on the flip side of
this amberhead's side counter sued and
stated that johnny had ruined her career
by colluding with adam waldman to
release images and allegations that she
was abusive to him abuse comes in many
forms either being verbal physical or
mentally which this case has went
through at several points heard took a
two-point strategy in firstly denying
that the op-ed was about him but she
also stated that he was abusive to her
so even if they ruled that it was
written with him in mind that it's still
true on the last day though she did kind
of slip up and admit that the op-ed was
about him which meant that she had to
basically double down on the second
point to cover her bases i told this
jury under oath that you had no idea
that the paparazzi would be at the
courthouse on may 27 2016. you didn't
expect a tmz employee to show up to
testify that tmz had been alerted that
you would be at the courthouse and knew
exactly which side of your face to take
a picture of did you
i know how many people will come out and
say whatever for him that's his power
that's why i wrote the op-ed is i was
speaking to that phenomenon how many
people will come out in support of him
and will fall to his power he is a very
powerful man and people love currying
favor we're powerful men correct
jail time for committing perjury
excuse me
i didn't i didn't hear your questions
ms vazquez if you do mine please just
repeat the question i didn't hear you
curry favor and commit perjury in this
courtroom
i have such a powerful man i have seen
people do this time and time again as
i've been covering this trial i've had
many people also bring up the libel case
in london saying that this definitely
proves hurd was the sole victim but that
was never against her rather it was
against the sun newspaper they printed a
story about the entire situation and
depp was suing them for libel however he
would have only won this if he could
prove that they knew the story was false
and still knowingly printed it this is
of course impossible to prove to a
newspaper and as they were given amber's
evidence they ran with it i never
thought johnny should have gone that
rude and in all honesty you might
remember that he ended up having to
leave fantastic beasts after the verdict
of it this isn't about proving what's
really happened it's about proving the
op-ed was either about johnny or that it
wasn't no defamation cases are rarely
won because it's so difficult to out and
outside for definite these kinds of
allegations however at least in the eyes
of the jury debt proved his side either
way i think that deb basically wanted to
get his side of the story out there as
we've pretty much only heard what
happened from amber though there were
clips photos and recordings released by
johnny they never had the full weight of
the media behind them like hurts did and
it never got the attention it also
deserved at least in my opinion now what
does this verdict really mean well it's
something that the media aren't fully
reporting on truthfully and when you
boil it down to its most basic terms if
the jury believed that depp had abused
amber then he would have lost this case
so though they aren't lining it out this
is bad for herd because it means she
either didn't provide enough evidence to
back up her claims or that they were as
fake as depp said they were this is why
it's very damaging for her story because
it states that she lied which was
further followed up in the decision on
her side now the count that heard one on
relates to the statement made by depp's
team that she and her friends called the
police to make it look like they'd been
a domestic disturbance when they then
left it was stay that they staged the
scene to make it look like there'd been
a fight and they called the police once
more so she won on this claim being
defamatory however the two counts that
she lost on were centered around the
entire thing being a hoax had heard used
as a weapon against depp this is really
bad for her public image and it will
likely have massive ramifications on her
career there's a lot of talk from people
who support herd at the moment that
public opinion was heavily influenced by
tick-tock and youtubers who
cherry-picked clips to hammer home that
she was the one at fault but this jury
didn't have any outside influences and
they were under strict instructions to
not watch any coverage of the trial
there's also people saying that those
who support deb didn't really watch the
trial but i've seen this used alongside
them saying the uk one was right even
though it wasn't televised either way i
don't think this verdict has really
changed people's mind on who they're
supporting for the rest of the video
we're going to be going over the last
two days the statements that were made
and how i believe they ended up
influencing this decision now our last
video released just after kate moss took
to the stand and from this point onwards
we had several last minute testimonies
this included morgan tremaine an ex-tmz
employee who discussed the photographs
taken of heard leaving the courthouse
with bruises on her face herders denied
tipping off the outlet and though he
didn't confirm whether she was the
source that told them to be there he
went over the entire situation and how
they get their info
and who were the type of sources that
tmc
received tips from um they would receive
tips from oftentimes it would be
publicists
managers agents or b-list celebrities
lawyers
and lawyers definitely
how are tips verified
tips are verified
by an extensive process if they come in
through our tip line we have to verify
who sent it
that
they um that the source is truthful and
so they have to add their contact
information which is a field in that um
on that website for like name uh phone
number
things like that
and how long did that process typically
take if we receive a tip through the tip
line
it could take a while because
that would need to be if it was a tip we
would need to verify it if it was media
such as photos or videos that need to be
extensively verified to ensure that the
person sending it is the copyright
holder and that we would have the legal
ability to air it and distribute it
and while working for tmz were you
involved in any assignments related to
ms heard i was
what was the first time you recall
working on an assignment related to ms
heard i believe it was may 27 2016.
and what was your role in that
assignment
for that it ms heard was filing a uh
restraining order at a courthouse in
downtown los angeles so um i dispatched
camera people to that location
under what circumstances would you
normally send paparazzi to a courthouse
uh only if we had been informed prior
it's not by any means a celebrity hot
spot um we would only ever send people
there if we had been tipped off that
something was occurring and there was
somebody present there
and what footage was tnc trying to
capture at the la court house on may
27th 2016. we were trying to capture uh
amber leaving the courthouse
and an alleged bruise on the right side
of her face
what was your team of paparazzi supposed
to do while they were at the la
courthouse on may 27 2016. their
objective was to capture her leaving the
courthouse
and then
she was going to sort of stop and turn
towards the camera to display the bruise
on the right side of her face deal edge
bruce
did your team of videographers get the
shot of amber heard we did
what is the difference between receiving
a tip from a news producer at any other
source
um if it's any other source it would
have to be verified
by copyright if it was anything that
was received
directly through a news producer then
they go through that process
to verify
the source
did you do anything to verify the tip on
may 27 2016 related to amber heard i did
not
why not
because it come directly from a news
producer
does that mean it had been verified
it means that they had verified that tip
and deemed that it was credible and
therefore a camera person needed to be
dispatched
so this testimony basically states that
it was either hid herself or someone
very close to her that tipped off tmz to
be at the courthouse this moment has
been criticized online because it's the
one time that heard stated she didn't
wear makeup to cover her bruises which
depths team have argued means had it
staged tremaine never got into who
tipped him off and he also discussed the
video of johnny slamming cabinets that
was sent to tmz tremaine actually went
viral for clapping back at herd's team
when they said he was just after his 15
minutes of fame you know this case is
being televised right i am aware that
there are cameras and so this gets you
your 15 minutes of fame objection your
honor argumentative
i can ask that question oh ruled
um
so i stand to gain nothing from this i'm
actually putting myself kind of in a
target of tmz a very litigious
uh organization
and i'm not seeking any 15 minutes here
though you may you're welcome to
speculate i could say the same thing by
taking amber hurt as a client for you
a little argumentative don't you think
oh hardly i find that to be purely
logical thank you now are you aware that
mr depp's attorneys were well aware of
the tro that was going to be
presented on may 27th objection calls
for speculation were you aware of that
lack of foundation
overworld if you can answer it can you
restate the question were you aware that
mr depp's divorce attorneys were aware
that amber heard was going in to see the
tro on may 27th
i don't think i understand the question
i don't think so now
okay do you know
whether blair burke one of mr depp's
divorce attorneys has a very close had a
very close relationship with tmz at that
time objection calls for speculation
overruled
if he knows
i was not aware of that okay and
when you said that you were dispatched
twice once to film amber for in the
parking lot for the deposition and then
it didn't work out and so you had to do
it another time how did you know it
didn't work out because tmz.com posted
an article saying as much okay i was not
dispatched do you know why the
deposition did not work out i'd have to
reference the article i forget so so do
you i didn't write that story i wasn't
involved in the actual journalism which
side
do you know which side would have known
or not known whether that deposition was
going to work out in other words the
people representing mr deb or the people
representing him is hurt i wouldn't know
and from here we had dr shannon curry
take the stand once more she basically
went over the finer points of her first
testimony and then also went over dr
hughes's counter one in case you don't
know curry basically outlined that amber
had bpd and had fabricated most of her
story about depp whilst hugh said the
complete opposite and stated that it was
all true in her opinion curry was called
back and went over the ptsd tests that
she had given to amber and she stated
that in her opinion hughes made the test
fit the results that she wanted rather
than the other way around which is how
it should be curry also stated that the
test purposely has questions in it that
are put in there to detect people faking
ptsd these will seem like genuine ones
but people who answer them are likely
trying to give the impression that they
have it when they really don't
um so
dr hughes
generally said that testing supported
ptsd
and that there was an etiology for her
trauma of intimate partner violence
she did reference that
essentially the
i can't remember if she said that the
trauma symptom inventory
indicated ptsd but she did say that the
elevation on that validity scale is
consistent with ptsd and that's simply
not true
that scale was designed and has been
tested and shown to be there to show
when somebody is endorsing extremely
unusual items that are not consistent
with ptsd and even though when some
people are experiencing ptsd their
distress level is so high that they'll
engage in what we call a cry for help
and they may sometimes exaggerate
distress again when you're looking at
scores as high as miss herds
and then you're not seeing indications
of ptsd and the more
subtle tests where she doesn't know what
she's endorsing
there's
it's good evidence that her
over-endorsement on that one test
is because of the reason the scale was
made to detect exaggeration and feigning
of symptoms
is this the test that uh
resulted in the 98 percentile
yes on that square on that atypical
response scale and what is that 98
percentile score represent
so that 98th percentile score just
represents that
among 98 98 of people who take that test
would not have endorsed
[Music]
she
scored more of those unusual items that
are not consistent with ptsd than 98 of
people who have ever taken that test
does that relate to this concept you
talked about before called feigning
yes what is feigning again
well feigning is essentially
exaggerating
symptoms of a disorder
hughes pretty much said the opposite to
this but curry stated that she shouldn't
have given her statement as fact without
also examining johnny she questioned
whether this self-reporting was ethical
and then went on to talk about whether
she believed heard had ptsd or not dr
hughes says that misheard has ptsd do
you agree i do not why not
the role results of my multi-method
comprehensive evaluation based on
carefully selected researched relevant
test meth test instruments
based on comparing those instruments to
misheard self-report observing miss
herd's behavior over 12 direct hours of
assessment
reviewing copious notes from prior
therapists who indicated symptoms in
their notes reviewing the notes of nurse
philadelphi previously nurse forum who
spent
i believe at one point almost two months
with misheard daily
reviewing the notes of her treating
providers
let's see
all of the legal documents and discovery
there was no evidence of ptsd
how is evidence of ptsd
generally
exhibited
so
really the bottom line in a forensic
psychological evaluation
is
a change in functioning that's what
we're looking for again i said we don't
have a crystal ball we're not wizards we
can't get into somebody's head
what we're looking for were their
identifiable changes
in the way the person engaged in their
world were they able to keep a job ptsd
is an extremely disabling diagnosis
when a person has true ptsd it is
difficult for them to work you'll see
unemployment job loss
it causes extreme levels of distress and
impairment there's divorce there's
isolation and estrangement from children
from family members
extreme alcohol abuse often a string of
sudden duis when the person never had
any before they become homebound they
can't go to the store
they're certainly not going to events
they're not
having success in their film career
usually they're not exercising every day
pursuing their hobbies being avid
readers obtaining level three sommelier
training having dinner parties with
friends speaking to public groups
those are just
indications of very high functioning and
when you're looking for a decrease in
functioning over time that is
inconsistent with that decrease from
here we got a discussion on the
photographs that amber submitted as
evidence johnny's team brought forth a
metadata expert to go over some of the
items amber had submitted which was then
rebuffed by her witness i try and keep
my opinion out of this stuff but i
really don't know why amber and her team
thought it was wise to submit this
photograph as two separate pieces when
when you can tell
it's the same photo isn't it amber said
that one was taken with a vanity light
on and the other without one but if you
zoom in and look at even the flecks of
hair they're all in the exact same
position which i think would be
absolutely impossible to do by accident
to me this was a major point in the case
that i was surprised heard's team
actually allowed her to submit and deb's
side even placed the images over the top
of each other to show how they lined up
and mr newmeister what's your um
what do we see here in this
demonstration
um
there's uh
exhibit seven twelve i believe you have
unassured debates number seven twelve
and seven thirteen
uh they're two separate exhibits except
it's the exact same photograph that's
been
uh one's been edited one hasn't or i
can't say that one hasn't but
the colors have been uh modified in an
editor objection your honor
uh beyond the scope of your ruling
talking about colors
it keeps happening
thank you
now he was also asked about the bruce
photographs
and mr newmeister what is this
demonstrative show about the photos that
you analyzed
well they appear to be
similar however if you look below at the
file sizes
one on the left is 712 kilobytes the one
in the middle is 489 kilobytes
and the one on the right is 524
kilobytes
now what's unusual about that is these
photos will not digitally fingerprint
with each other they won't hash in other
words forensically they don't match
but
the thing is you could say well it was
sent through email maybe it's a
different size
this the file sizes
for example would be
possibly
uh you know you can select the file size
you send a photo but there's no way to
authenticate any photo that was
presented in the way the evidence was
collected
and so what conclusions do you draw from
that well there's this is just three of
many of the same type of photos that are
all different sizes and have different
chromatic which means connection your
honor we just had a ruling on this
all right sustained injection mr
investor stick to your opinions that
relate specifically to what you analyzed
about the exif data please all three of
these photos had to go through some type
of transformation to change sizes
amber's team then brought in their own
expert but he kind of scored an own goal
on it sir you just
agreed with me
that those two photos
are different photos
correct
i agree that they were visually
different yes right so they are two
visually different photos
that were created at the exact same
hour
the exact same minute
the exact same second
as each other correct
and that's what the daytime metadata
shows yes
and the metadata shows something else
too
they have the exact same file name don't
they sir
yes but that's not embedded metadata so
again he just confirms this is the same
photo which we all knew and i really
don't understand why the legal team
allowed this to be submitted as two
separate images this was a case that was
built massively around amber's
credibility and it was such a risk
submitting this in the first place now
another thing that was a major risk was
allowing both amber and johnny to take
the stand again in court you rarely want
to have your client giving testimony
because it gives the other side a chance
to bring out as many things against you
as they can this is why whenever you
watch movies based on trials they tend
to have say the murderer not testifying
or at least not being advised to hood's
team really didn't waste any time either
and they brought out so many text
messages that made depp look bad i'm not
going to analyze this and that's the
same with amber's statement as it goes
over some pretty graphic stuff and i run
the risk of making light of certain
things but the testimonies are out in
full on youtube if you want to see them
throughout this whole thing i've tried
to put myself in the position of the
jury and i know that if it was me i'd be
focused on what the witnesses and
experts say rather than what the people
involved in it themselves do as there's
more chance of them being biased whether
this was an ego played by depp's team or
not we will likely never know but having
depp understand once more also made
amber come forward as well and like i
said i don't think that she should have
done this it allowed camille vasquez to
go over everything all over again leave
it fresh in the jury's mind and she also
brought forth new evidence that she'd
been holding up her sleeve it was also
where amber basically said that she
wrote the op-ed about johnny and doing
this on the last two days for both sides
was extremely risky and in my opinion
led to the verdict that we got and that
takes us to the closing statements all
four lawyers took completely different
strategies and as always camille came
out with a barrage of evidence and also
the witnesses that testified against
amber these were all about 40 minutes
long i sat and watched them all all day
but huge shout outs to entertainment
tonight for cutting down the main
highlights ben chu followed this up by
going over the more emotional aspects of
it which was then counted by herd's
lawyer ben rottenborn who hasn't really
had the physical evidence throughout
this trial so he played up the hand he
had which was going over the emotional
testimony and how devastating it had
been for her elaine then came after this
and if you watched any of the live
streams like legal bites then you'll
know the lawyers thought she took a
pretty bad approach it was full of
sweeping statements based on very little
and was arguably the worst out of the
bunch using up all her team's time and
then allowing depth to have a massive
rebuttal this left hurts team with a six
minute rebuttal whereas depths had 39
because they were straight to the point
and didn't mess about ironically these
were dropped on may 27th six years to
the day that amber went to the
courthouse and an amber alert also went
off during rottenborn statement which
you couldn't make it up exactly six
years ago today
on may 27th 2016 miss herd walked into
court and filed a false report of
domestic abuse against her husband of 15
months johnny depp
the scene was a setup
she tipped off the paparazzi
so they would be waiting
they knew exactly where she would pause
which side of her face to photograph
and the photos captured what she wanted
them to see
the image of a battered woman
what the paparazzi did not know is that
the dark mark on her face mysteriously
appeared six days after last seen mr
depp
it was a lie
she knew it
mr depp knew it
and the multiple witnesses you heard
from who saw her that week of may 21
2016 also knew it
but the world only saw what she wanted
them to see
two years later
when promoting the biggest role of her
career
until this trial
ms hurd presented herself to the world
as a public figure representing domestic
abuse
the headline of the op-ed featured the
term sexual violence
even though she had never before accused
her ex-husband of such a heinous crime
ms hurd and her lawyers love to remind
you of how the op-ed did not mention mr
depp by name
but miss heard made sure that there
would be no mistake about who she was
referring to
she inserted
two years ago so the world would
remember the photo of a battered woman
the mark on her face
standing outside the courthouse and they
would once again see mr depp as the
villain
this time in full swing of the metoo
movement
but what was happening behind closed
doors was quite different from what ms
heard presented to the world
the exact opposite in fact
there is a there is an abuser in this
courtroom
but it is not mr deb
and there is a victim of domestic abuse
in this courtroom but it is not misheard
the evidence presented at this trial has
shown that miss heard is in fact the
abuser and mr depp the abused
as you heard from mr depp and multiple
other witnesses that testified under
oath
at this trial
mr depp experienced persistent verbal
physical and emotional abuse
by misheard during their relationship
you heard from mr depp about how often
miss heard would berate him insult him
and physically attack him including one
of the most serious occasions when
misheard threw a vodka bottle at mr deb
severely injuring his finger and then
put a cigarette out on his face
you heard from mr depp that this whole
incident in australia started because
miss heard was enraged that mr depp
wanted a post-nuptial agreement and she
wasn't in his will
just a month after getting married
you also heard from tara roberts a
manager at mr depp's island who
witnessed miss heard telling mr dev that
he was washed up and would die fat and
lonely
you also heard from miss roberts that
she witnessed miss heard clawing and
grabbing at mr depp grabbing his hair
trying to pull him back to her and mr
depp had a visible injury to his nose on
that occasion
most importantly you heard from miss
heard yourselves
on multiple audio recordings admitting
to being physically violent with mr depp
what you didn't hear on a single
recording you heard in this case
and there were many played by both
parties is mr depp ever admitting to
hitting punching or kicking miss heard
you didn't hear it
it doesn't exist
it didn't happen
and despite the fact that mr deaf and
misheard are heard discussing many of
the alleged incidents you've heard about
at this trial like australia and the
bahamas
you never heard miss heard accuse mr
depp of sexual assault
unlike mr depp who you heard admit to
and own up to his past mistakes and his
struggles particularly with drugs and
alcohol
misheard will not admit
that she has never done that she has
ever done anything wrong
but she cannot deny what you heard on
those recordings as much as miss heard
and her lawyers have tried to make this
case about mr depp's language
it is misheard that repeatedly admits to
violence
when you catch misheard in a lie she
tries to cover it up with more lies
so let's talk about the giant lie at the
heart of this case
miss herd's claim that mr depp is an
abusive monster
and that she is a public figure
representing domestic abuse she spun a
story of shocking overwhelming brutal
abuse
she came into this courtroom prepared to
give the performance of her life and she
gave it
misheard miss herd's acting coach
christina sexton testified that miss
heard has difficulty crying when she is
acting
you saw it
miss heard sobbing without tears
while spinning elaborate exaggerated
fantastical accounts of abuse
and everything going on in her mind
almost a decade prior while enduring
that abuse
it was a performance what we have is a
mountain of unproven allegations that
are wild
over the top and implausible
and you can't pick and choose which of
these wild allegations to believe and
which ones to disregard
you either believe all of it or none of
it
either mr depp sexually assaulted
misheard with a bottle in australia
or misheard god up on that stand
in front of all of you
and made up that horrific tale of abuse
either she's a victim of truly horrific
abuse
or she is a woman who is willing to say
absolutely anything but this case
doesn't come down to whether you believe
misheard or you believe mr depp
this case comes down to whether you
believe misheard
or you believe
mr depp
christy dombrowski
sean bett
malcolm connolly
travis mcgivern
starling jenkins
keenan wyatt
dr kipper
nurses debbie lloyd and aaron fellotti
tara roberts
ben king
kate james
kate moss
dr colber
morgan knight
morgan tremaine
officers melissa signs
officers tyler hadden
officer william gatlin
and beverly leonard
before amber heard ladies and gentlemen
no woman ever
no woman ever before amber heard ever
claimed that mr depp raised a hand to
her in his 58 years
and no other woman since
miss heard made that false claim back on
may 17 may 27 2016
has and repeated it in her december 2018
op-ed
has any woman come forward since
this is me too
without any me too
to the contrary ladies and gentlemen you
heard kate moss two days ago
testified this is a woman who has never
testified in any proceeding ever
a very private person
testified that mr depp never abused her
and that miss heard lied to you and she
lied to you twice beyond the personal
and emotional effects of miss heard's
lies
their impact on mr depp and his family
the damage she inflicted on his
reputation and career is undeniable
there's an old saying that a good
reputation takes a lifetime to build
but only a second to destroy
mr depp spent in fact a lifetime
building his reputation as one of the
greatest actors and movie stars of this
generation an iconic figure respected
through and liked throughout hollywood
and recognized and admired throughout
the world as you heard in this case
amber heard is not a true victim and mr
depp certainly is not an abuser
again
nobody has come out of the woodwork to
say me too
this is the unique and singular me too
case where there's not a single me too
she did a better recap than me now
benshu constantly bringing up me too and
saying there was no me too was a line
that really stuck out and i think
whatever the result that they delivered
two powerful statements next we go to
rottenborn and elaine in mr depp's world
you don't leave mr death
and if you do
he will start a campaign of global
humiliation against you
a smear campaign
that lasts to this very day
he will do everything he can
to destroy your life
to destroy your career
that is what they are saying ladies and
gentlemen
and that's what they're trying to get
you
the jury to be an accomplice to
but it's not surprising
because mr death
cannot and will not take responsibility
for his own actions
it's always someone else's fault does
the first amendment give miss heard the
right to write the words that she wrote
in this article
on december 18 2018
that's the question
and you cannot simultaneously protect
and uphold the first amendment and find
in favor of johnny depp on his claim you
simply cannot you have to decide should
someone be able to write an article like
that in the united states of america
without being sued successfully without
having to go through the hell that miss
hurt has gone through think about every
piece of evidence that you've heard over
the last six weeks about his abuse about
their relationship
none of that is in the article
none of it
we all know that it would be a very
different article if she had written
about what she suffered that she's told
you about over the last six weeks
because he knows the words are true mr
depp says that the words now have a
defamatory implication he says the
statements are the same as saying
johnny depp abused me
but just because he wants to make the
article about himself doesn't mean it is
he has to show you
that any defamatory implication was
designed and intended
look at number four designed and
intended by ms heard to convey the
defamatory meaning that he suggests just
because people might read the article
and remember oh yeah amber heard used to
be married to johnny depp
and she accused him of abuse that
doesn't mean that she designed and
intended defamatory implications
in writing about herself and think about
it if mr depp is right then virtually
any statement that anyone could ever
make about their own life
that implies anything implies any
involvement with any other person could
be defamatory and that's clearly not
what the first amendment
intends
she didn't design and attend the words
to be the equivalent of writing johnny
depp abuse me and you don't have to take
her words for it you can take the words
of terrence doherty of the aclu he said
that the op-ed wasn't even miss heard's
idea
the aclu wrote the first draft and great
care was taking taken in drafting the
article so as not to make it about mr
death or miss heard's relationship with
him
that's the only evidence presented about
miss heard's motive except her admit her
statements that that was exactly what
she wanted to do she wanted to talk
about her experiences after johnny depp
ms heard didn't write the headline
she didn't approve the headline
she had nothing to do with it
she was not given notice of the headline
she testified you saw her testify about
the sexual assault that she experienced
at the hands of mr deb you saw her
testify about that that they're calling
her a liar
you saw her on the stand testify with
your own mouth
with her own mouth
exactly
exactly what she went through
for the first time in court because
people
who have suffered that they don't want
to broadcast that to the world
they want to penalize miss heard for not
speaking about that earlier that's
ridiculous and it's insulting and it's
just victim blaming at its most
disgusting
you can't restore his reputation you
can't give him anything they didn't tell
you that but the court told you that and
that's a very very important thing here
he told his story he had his
opportunities he had his full
opportunities to do all of that and he
came in here and lied to you and said
he's here to get his reputation back
it's just one of many lies in this case
but it's a really big one because here
we are
six weeks of your time precious time six
weeks of this court's time
for what
for nothing
only to go after amber
that's psychological abuse
he's going after amber for nothing
because he wants to put her through this
again
the third time
so we're fighting back and that's the
counter plane
she finally has said enough enough
and we're asking you to finally
hold this man responsible he has never
accepted responsibility for anything in
his life once again the next day
johnny apologizes to amber he says in
two different text messages that 772 and
773
he says my profound apologies in one of
them and my apologies are eternal in the
other one what is he apologizing for the
next day on may 22nd if he didn't know
that he did all of those things she
wasn't wearing any makeup she was
natural she wasn't wearing a stitch of
makeup every one of them says it's the
exact same thing why would you say that
she's an actor she's not going to go
outside her house you know without
putting makeup on and if she has bruises
why on earth when she's been covering
them up for four years why on earth
would she not put makeup on so that she
would cover those up
why on earth would she not want to cover
up those bruises it makes no sense but
you know what you guys saw her here you
guys sorry um you saw amber on the stand
there were days where she didn't wear
eye makeup
a lot of people think that she's not
wearing makeup when she doesn't have
mascara
and eyeliner on she has different looks
and some of them are with eye makeup and
some of them are without and people
misunderstand especially people that
aren't that good at makeup and a lot of
men frankly um go oh that's then she
probably doesn't have makeup and that's
where that mistake happens but you heard
her testimony and you heard her makeup
artist testimony saying she doesn't go
out of her room without concealer and
foundation she knows how to put these
things in and you saw defendants exhibit
155 and you'll have the actual thing in
there that's the type of palette she
used and she was very adept at telling
you what color she puts on for the
different days of bruises this is a
woman who for four years did everything
she could to cover up anybody knowing
anything about this abuse do you
honestly think she's just going to walk
around for the week with her bruises
exposed of course she's not if you do
the math amber is entitled at least 31.5
what does she take seven million what
does she do with the seven million she
gives it to charity or she intends to
give it to charity now they make much
ado about the pledge versus donation but
both the corporate designees for aclu
and for children's hospital said
donation and pledge are interchangeable
these are pledges the aclu corporate
designee said you typically do pledges
because of the tax benefits and that's
what she said she pledged it over a
period of time because of the tax
implications to it and because she was
getting paid over the time now she
started to make these donations and
you'll see that the first one was on
behalf of mr depp's uh business manager
mr white actually sent the letters with
the hundred thousand for each of those
that was the initial ones
he was trying to take credit for those
and in fact both the aclu and children's
hospital got confused and gave the
credit to mr depp not to amber for those
then she made payments to both and elon
musk also made payments to both for 500
000 each which she didn't count to her
pledge but they helped those
organizations at the end of the day
she's made a million dollars in pledge
in payments to them but then she got
sued here and hasn't been able to
because she spent six million dollars in
attorney's fees that is unrefuted she
still intends to pay those pledges honor
those pledges and she said that
throughout and i elicited from both the
aclu and from children's hospital they
haven't expired she can pay them
whenever she wants to and she fully
intends to but she has to get out from
under this first they started to get
amber fired from aquaman too they have
continued to this day they have followed
her everywhere everybody has stopped
wanting her l'oreal won't use her even
though they've kept her on from that
time she lost three different
opportunities that were being discussed
with her the most significant part of
that though is that aquaman was the
biggest blockbuster ever for dc films it
was the biggest it was over a billion
dollars this was her opportunity for her
star even the experts from mr depp
admitted this was her blockbuster this
was her mega but what happened instead
as she's going through as it's coming
out and in that 16 months they were
going well nothing happened yeah lots
happened she was had three different
films she was discussing she had she got
the l'oreal contract she she got the
stand all of those things were happening
because of aquaman and then everything
shut down she wasn't allowed to do
publicity for the stand she wasn't
allowed to uh she you know hasn't been
allowed to do anything for l'oreal she
got shut down from her charitable
organizations she she ended up not
getting the amazon movie and then they
gave her a hard time about aquaman two
and instead of the career trajectory of
the other comparators who all went way
up and by the way all the experts admit
that that career trajectory went well
for all the rest of them and she's the
only one that didn't have it and the
reason is because of the defamatory
statements now camille fired back to
rottenborn that the first amendment
didn't cover hate speech and elaine also
said something very stupid she said she
didn't want them to take the hundred
million dollars that they were suing for
all she said was they wanted some
damages back which wasn't exactly the
smartest strategy but either way that
was the trial and the jury deliberated
over the holiday weekend in the us now
that brings us to the verdict which i
watched live and we even had a bit where
they had to delay the decision because
the jury didn't fill out the form
correctly it was very tense but it did
hint that someone had indeed won in the
end they found that the article was
defamatory and that amber pushed the
idea that depp was abusive to destroy
his career since then the pair have both
released statements ambers reads the
disappointment i feel today is beyond
words i'm heartbroken that the mountain
of evidence still was not enough to
stand up to the disproportionate power
influence and sway of my ex-husband i'm
even more disappointed with what this
verdict means for other women it is a
setback it sets back the clock to a time
when a woman who spoke up and spoke out
could be publicly shamed and humiliated
sets back the idea that violence against
women is to be taken seriously i believe
johnny's attorney succeeded in getting
the jury to overlook the key issues of
freedom of speech and ignore evidence
that was so conclusive that we won in
the uk i'm sad i lost this case but i am
sadder still i seem to have lost a ride
i thought i had as an american to speak
freely and open now johnny's reads six
years ago my life the life of my
children the lives of those closest to
me and also the lives of the people who
for many many years have supported and
believed in me were forever changed all
in the blink of an eye false very
serious and criminal allegations were
levied at me by the media which
triggered an endless barrage of hateful
content although no charges were ever
brought against me it had already
traveled around the world twice within a
nanosecond and it had a seismic impact
on my life and my career and six years
later the jury gave me my life back i am
truly humbled my decision to pursue this
case knowing very well the height of the
legal hurdles that i would be facing and
the inevitable worldwide spectacle into
my life was only made after considerable
thought from the very beginning the girl
of bringing this case was to reveal the
truth regardless of the outcome speaking
the truth was something i owe to my
children and to all those who remain
steadfast in their support of me i feel
at peace knowing i've firmly
accomplished that after hearing this his
lawyers said this their careful
deliberation
to the judge and the court staff who
have devoted an enormous amount of time
and resources towards this case
our judicial system is predicated on
each person's right to have his or her
case heard
and we were honored truly honored to
assist mr depp in ensuring that his case
was fairly considered throughout the
trial we are also most pleased that the
trial has resonated for so many people
in the public who value truth and
justice
now that the jury has reached its
conclusive verdict it's time to turn the
page and look to the future thank you
all so much and thanks to the jury thank
you so much
so whether either will work again
remains to be seen but i think that depp
will at least now have the vindication
to get his career back on track depp has
said he would never go back to work with
disney on pirates of the caribbean but i
do think there might at least be some
negotiations there as for heard we know
her role is massively cut down in
aquaman 2 and whether she continues as
this character remains to be seen this
trial could potentially bankrupt him and
i doubt the charities will ever receive
the money that she pledged now this
trial obviously has a lot going on with
it i've admitted that i've had some
biases throughout and i think that
everyone will have their own biases when
it comes to it i think that no matter
what the verdict is people have watched
the trial seen the clips and have made
up their own mind so today's verdict
doesn't even really matter that much the
way i see it there's team johnny team
amber team i don't care and team they
both suck i think that going forward
this trial will have a long legacy to it
as not only are the implications of
abuse being talked about openly but it
also has two extremely famous people
airing their dirty laundry there's also
the legal side of it and some of the
cross-examinations i think will be used
in law schools to show how one should
approach a witness now there is of
course the heavier side of this and i
know that there are victims out there
that have been affected by this trial if
you are one of them then please go to
victim support and if you're in the uk
that's
victimsupport.org uk it's a great
organization that can help with domestic
violence and if you're going through
something or have been through it then
please reach out to them anyway that
wraps up the trial and i hope you
enjoyed the coverage kinda went back and
forth over whether to keep covering this
and also i've had several tms from
people angry at me but i felt it was
necessary to talk about and thank you to
everyone who sent kind messages over our
coverage hope to see you back at the
channel soon and we have a video linked
on screen right now just for you without
the way thanks for sitting through this
i've been paul and i'll see you next
time take care peace